when I read about you getting the part
on Mad Men and like the famously seven
auditions like seven [ __ ] auditions
at every one of those steps
if I would have sucked it would have
been
out bounced next yeah I was watching
some dude I don't know whether he was
director of the show or creator of the
show they were interviewing him and he's
talking about how no one wanted you they
didn't want you not because of your
acting they didn't want you because you
weren't a name they wanted a name for
exactly All Odds were against you
getting this thing I mean it was a game
changer I mean it really isn't so easy
to get that gig but why then you have to
do the job yeah yeah and then you got to
be good yeah
Why seven was because I started at the
very very very bottom I was not even on
the list so I wasn't
I remember I'll I'll never forget it I
remember the first audition for this
show is for the casting directors who I
hadn't met because they were based in
New York City
and it was at a uh it was at an
advertising agency uh in Santa Monica
I lived over in Los Feliz Silver Lake so
I lived on the other side of L.A and La
people will know that that is not an
easy commute
especially in February when it was
raining so it took me about two hours to
get to this audition where I'm sitting
next to like a 15 year old kid
waiting you know a sign-in sheet and
waiting and the kid goes a year for the
toothpaste commercial and I go what
no and then I thought well maybe I could
get a job on that toothpaste yeah
why not like yeah nice taste but uh I
was like maybe maybe I could double dip
on this it's a two-hour drive another
two hours on the way back it's still
raining so in other words you weren't
thinking you weren't walking in there
thinking this was going to be the
biggest break of my career if I get this
thing like I definitely I walked in
there thinking I really really liked
this script I remember reading the
script and and putting it down and
thinking holy [ __ ] that's a that's a
really good story and then I read it
again to make sure I didn't make it up
in my head that I was better than it was
I was like no this is really good so I
really wanted I really wanted it do you
ever get into like who else went up for
that role because when you start at the
bottom you don't know but then you get
to the third the fourth audition and
then you start to go wait a second I
could get this [ __ ] thing this might
be a real opportunity this could
actually happen then the and yeah you're
in the running
do you start to like who else is up for
this thing you know there's a sign-in
sheet like people are there's names and
you can look at the names who's signed
in it's not just the kid going out for
the toothpaste ad anymore and now it's
people whose names you start to
recognize the only name
that I remember from any of those
sign-in sheets and I've since heard that
oh they were out to this guy and maybe
this guy was going to do it who knows
who knows how truly that is but the only
name I remember
from that sign issue was Josh Molina who
I'm not sure had a great shot at being
Don Draper but it would have been a
choice you know it would have been and I
love John he's a great wonderful actor
foreign